[Music]
waiting for for jacob we're waiting for
him to finish in the bathroom he's
marking this state as his territory
i'm gonna be so upset if he's taller
than me
[Music]
[Music]
holy [ __ ] yes i'm taller
[Music]
i saw it
i see him
he is taller than us oh my god how you
guys doing this is crazy
[Music]
what an embarrassing place to start that
look at anna anna say hi
i think an economic on around here oh
maybe
[Music]
i went on a little journey by myself and
i got our storyboard artist with molly
uh
can you game with the robot hand
[Music]
right on board
maybe some fortnight
get me some
[Music]
in my own fortnite
i am
[Music]
no way you can actually tell he's not
wearing underwear because he's commando
spawn
hey look it's that female terminator
that's that lady from mortal kombat
legacy or whatever the stupid tv show
was
looks like lobo got punched in the face
oh [ __ ] that's a difference yo look the
the maplex wolverine
oh i found it i found the that page
oh dear god
[Music]
hey do you want to tell do you want to
tell everyone what happened
because you look awfully sad
i'm frustrated
i was in the line for food
for like 30 minutes
and then i get there and they have
nothing left on the menu except chili
philly cheese steaks
i ordered two because i think ah maybe
you know someone will want one right
and then they hand it to me and i'm
struggling to hold both of them and then
it spills and then gets cheese all over
my sleeve
and they won't give me a replacement one
and these fries are unsalted and cold
and then they made that entire lemonade
in front of me
for about like 10 minutes
instead of just having it in like a big
container so you know you can just pour
it
so everyone in the entire line is
waiting for lemonade for extra 10
minutes per person
and by the time i got here my pizza was
cold
i'm having a bad spider-man time the
cheesesteak
diego
i don't know
why not
first
get here no one even wants the
cheesecake
is the pizza place
you might complain about them
not as bad as he makes it
at least someone gets something out of
this whole ordeal
and some bitter lemonade
it's not even good lemonade
not good
that's part of the convention experience
it
all right we are back on the move
after that disappointing [ __ ] fiasco
with xavier
[Music]
this guy loves legos
he likes walking up to them
it's a disneyland
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
dammit
[Music]
hey jacob striker poles
yeah all the way to the right
yeah there you go
andrew toby oh yeah
nice
[Music]
yeah all right yeah so that way we don't
have
[Music]
normal
[Music]
[Music]
travis is kill or be killed
[Music]
we got anna
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
yeah this is phoenix
[Music]
get a picture with it with the
lightsaber
[Music]
i'm broken
help each other out
adjust each other's top play
[Music]
look at this little guy he keeps just
driving around
[Applause]
you look good
i love that movie that's my favorite
[Music]
dude you gotta get that that [ __ ] is so
good have you seen those okay what is
this so these are neca figures it comes
with all four of them and literally like
every accessory neca has ever made for
these figures
okay do you want to see how much
these are usually
this is usually only 200 on amazon it is
200. yeah yeah okay
oh yeah i've actually i've seen that in
target it's a it's a gingerbread
spiderman whatever this is
who wants that i don't know
[Music]
bird chick
[Music]
dude that lightsaber is so sick
it looks so good on camera yeah
holy [ __ ] oh my god
holy [ __ ] whoa we should ask we juggle
lightsabers
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
you